some breaking news this morning right
now las vegas boulevard closed at sahara
metro police
shot and killed domain early this
morning hector mejia has been there all
morning long for us he is live on scene
with the very latest hi hector
taylor good morning and the
investigation here continues right
behind us
and looking at the small codes you see
on the ground here on the las vegas
strip
those orange colored cones the small
ones there it looks like
that police chase traveled southbound on
las vegas boulevard and off in the
distance where you see those flashing
lights
that is where police that's where
they're focusing their investigation
near the resorts that is
south of the sahara las vegas closer to
the hilton grand vacations
and that is the end of a police chase
this happened just after midnight
it started with a traffic stop but
police say the driver sped away as they
waited for backup
the suspect was armed and had several
felony warrants according to metro
at some point the driver turned on the
strip officers shot and killed that
person who is accused of holding a knife
in their hand
and charging at police none of the
officers were hurt
so look at the end of the day this is
the las vegas boulevard we're going to
do everything in our power to keep it
safe to protect the residents of las
vegas and the tourists that come here
every year and we will do whatever we
can to make sure that you know we don't
have vehicles at a high rate of speed
going down and putting anybody at risk
we're told this is the 15th officer
involved shooting of 2020 for metro
police well that's the latest here on
the scene now
again both directions of las vegas
boulevard are closed right now right at
sahara
let's send it over to nate tannenbaum in
case this is part of your morning
commute
to get around this hey there nate thank
you so much hector yeah it's unusual to
have the strip closed at any time
if there's any good news there's not a
whole lot of traffic there during the
overnight hours but this has been closed
for more than six and a half hours so
you cannot get on the strip between
sahara
and elvis presley boulevard that used to
be called riviera boulevard the bottom
line the investigation
is ongoing